es lo que se espera para las próximas
horas seguramente después de este ataque
israelí en la franja de gaza que se
denominó operación despertar del alba y
que como bien detallado hacer según el
enlace de fuerzas israelíes dejó en
alrededor de 15 terroristas muertos
incluyendo al comandante de la yihad
islámica taysir al yabari entre las 8
víctimas entre las ocho víctimas
mortales señaladas por el ministerio de
salud de gaza se encuentra una niña de
cinco años y también 44 heridos fueron
seis objetivos de la yihad islámica los
que dijeron las fuerzas de defensa
israelí de saber atacado entre ellos un
edificio residencial y rápidamente llegó
la respuesta del líder de la yihad
islámica siad al najar quien prometió
que no hay líneas rojas y que tel aviv
es un objetivo y que no hay lugar para
la tregua después de este ataque de allí
entonces que israel haya activado la
cúpula de hierro el sistema de defensa
antiaéreo para tel aviv jerusalén y ber
sheva mientras que el primer ministro
israelí yair lapid dijo que estos
ataques se deben a que los terroristas
no a marcar la agenda en casa y además
de arrestar a whatsapp alzada de israel
mató a un comandante de la yihad
islámica en gaza explíquenos quiénes son
estos personajes y cuál fue el detonante
para que israel se prepare para una
represalia
estáis ir al chaval y lo decíamos es
comandante era comandante mejor dicho en
el centro y el norte de gaza a cargo de
la unidad de lanzamiento de cohetes
hacia israel y había reemplazado a baja
abu alá está quien había sido asesinado
también en 2019 por las fuerzas
israelíes esto comenzó si se quiere con
bazán zar y el líder de la yihad
islámica que fue arrestado el lunes por
la noche en el campo de refugiados de
yenín era líder en cisjordania del grupo
y desde entonces israel temía una
represalia de estas organizaciones
palestinas de allí los 24 días de
bloqueo
que es algo poco habitual que israel
tome estas medidas contra su propia
población cuando no se encuentra en un
enfrentamiento está claro que para los
gazatíes que viven desde hace 15 años en
un bloqueo parcial esto también empeoró
la situación había generado cortes en
los suministros tanto de energía como de
productos básicos horas antes de que se
produjera esta operación el ministro de
defensa israelí benny gantz había
advertido que el tiempo se le acababa a
la chica dinámica para llegar a un
acuerdo y evitar la escalada luego de
que durante los últimos días mediadores
de egipto y de qatar intentarán evitar
que escalará el conflicto